اذا كل عام وانتم بخير تابعنا واياكم قبل
عناوين هذه النشره احتفالات العام الجديد
في نيوزيلندا
ودخول العام الجديد 2020 الاحتفالات لا
تزال مستمره في
نيوزيلندا كما نشاهد الان في هذه الصور
التي نقولها لكم مباشره على شاشه العربيه
احتفالا طبعا بدخول العام الجديد 2003
نشاهد الان هذه الصور من نيوزلندا وهي
الدوله التي تحتفل بدخول العام الجديد وهي
من اوائل طبعا الدول التي اطلت عليها همم
هذه السنه الجديده 2003
و20 همم وهذه الاحتفالات نشاهدها همم الان
همم امامنا طبعا بعد عامين كانت توصف
بانها
في الاحتفالات بسبب همم طبعا فيروس كرونه
والان هذه الصور وعوده التجمعات مره اخرى
وعوده الاحتفالات كذلك بدخول العام الجديد
2023 كل عام وانتم بخير